[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur figaro live
vous êtes au coeur du figaro vous êtes
en direct et on attend vos points de vue
notamment vos points de vue sur la
polémique du jour la colère des élus et
des plus hauts responsables de l'état
après la fermeture l'annoncé de la
fermeture de l'usiné de bridgetown dans
le nord que peut bien faire l'état on
attend bien vos commentaires vos points
de vue on va les confronter ce soir avec
ceux de vincent trémolet de villers
bonsoir lun 20 ans directeur adjoint de
la rédaction du figaro alors parmi vos
oeuvres la dernière en date rester
vivant ouvrage collectif
on y trouve deux dans les plus grandes
signatures qui se sont exprimées
notamment dans les pages du figaro
pendant la crise pendant le confinement
dans la crise du cornât virus qui n'est
pas fini on va y revenir et on a
notamment les contributions d'alain
finkielkraut julia de funès ou bien
sylvain tesson face avoue sylvain
courage
bonsoir s'il voit ravi de vous retrouver
ici
merci le plaisir et est content de
rejouer rédacteur en chef à l'ops loeb
ce qui fait sa une sur les écolos sont
ils crédibles avec notamment une
interview de yannick jadot
c'est un dossier très intéressant et
donc qui est à retrouver chez nouveaux
notamment chez vos marchands de journaux
en s'y vendent encore des journaux le
gouvernement a t-il raison d'intervenir
donc dans le dossier bridgestone c'est
la question qu'on pose aujourd'hui sur
le site du figaro vous pouvez voter
continuez de voter au lendemain de
l'annoncé de la fermeture brutale de
cette usine dont bridgestone à béthune
dans le nord le gouvernement est monté
au créneau en tout cas le créneau
rhétorique on a entendu ce matin jean
baptiste djebbari ensuite bruno le maire
vincent très mal et à part un numéro
d'indignation qu'est ce que le
gouvernement peut faire d'autre dans
cette affaire il doit faire de la
politique donc là il fait de la
politique avec un numéro d'indignation
qui n'est sans doute pas fin parce que
dans cette histoire c'est pas seulement
la symbolique ya des gens qui perdent
leur boulot et donc c'est quand même 800
emplois voilà c'est quand même le
premier effet de cette de cette histoire
donc il fonda politique en essayant de
montrer qu'ils sont indignés que 2,6
avaient mieux à j il aurait pu empêcher
ce phénomène
ce sont ces licences ce licenciement
massif moi il me semble que au delà de
la politique l'état ne peut pas faire
grand chose c'est à dire que la
bridgestone ya plusieurs éléments alors
on connaît pas encore l'intégralité du
dossier
mais il y a quand même des éléments
structurels économiques qui font que
ces pneus sont 20% plus cher que les
pneus qui arrivent de chine il ya un
élément qu'on a du mal encore à chiffrer
mais je pense de changements de
pratiques qui fait qu'à partir du moment
où la voiture recule dans un certain
nombre de sociétés occidentales est ce
que les marchands pneus sont les mêmes
perspectives qu autrefois
et enfin il ya l'attitude des dirigeants
de bridgestone qui ont peut-être usé de
cynisme ça ce sera à mes xavier bertrand
ait l'air te dire que oui puisqu'il
parle d'un assassinat prémédité mais
voilà et tous ces éléments là je pense
que l'état le plus performant de la
terre ne peut pas les empêcher c'est le
fonctionnement de l'économie alors après
il ya des petites choses qui sont
faisable et la conditionnalité ils ont
quand même été aidé par le cic ils ont
profité du chômage partiel
et puis après il ya des choses plus
simples à la conditionnalité c'est 2-2
d'obliger ces entreprises à une forme de
contrepartie
voilà du alors mais il ya des aides car
exemple dans les aides proposées par
bruno le maire à la suite du coup vide
il ya déjà une conditionnalité c'est un
peu il ya la relocalisation bon je saute
n'a pas pris des enfants dans le
corridor le chômage partiel faut quand
même préciser mais à la relocalisation
et la transition écologique ça c'est les
conditions qui sont qui sont donnés par
bruno le maire puis après y'a la
symbolique
bridgestone et des sponsors
des olympiques 2024 à paris bon en même
temps il fermer une usine avait une
peut-être que symboliquement anne
hidalgo ou le cio pourrait faire quelque
chose je joue ce mardi à la fin des
années 90 déjà l'état ne peut pas tout
quand on sait personne ne dit ça ni la
gauche a fortiori après l'épisode jospin
ni la droite puisque xavier bertrand
dont il est aussi le président de la
région mais enfin y'a pas un dirigeant
politique français aujourd'hui qui
pourrait même essayé d'expliquer la
logique économique de bridgestone là
c'est vraiment l'indignation parce qu'il
ya une incompréhension de la part
évidemment des ouvriers qui sont frappés
dans leur vie
ils sont là depuis toujours et ils vont
perdre leur emploi mais aussi de
l'opinion en général on entend dire
qu'il faut relocaliser la production
industrielle et on voit une
une usine fermée donc pour les gens
c'est incompréhensible alors il ya une
vraie logique économique parce qu'on
sait que c'est une industrie qui est
très intense en capital qu'il faut des
investissements lourds qu'ils n'ont pas
été fait puisque je crois qu'ils étaient
restés spécialisés sur des pneus pour
les petits véhicules d'entrée de gamme
ou là effectivement l'avantagé
concurrentiel de la de la localisation
français nul et donc l'état a aidé enfin
en tout cas il ya eu des aides publiques
mais la conditionnalité c'est aussi
d'être stratège il
il eût fallu que votre gestion de monte
en gamme pour fabriquer des puces
spécialisées 2 et suivait cela ferait de
braises chaudes mais en fin d'étape pas
fait ce que je sais pas comment vous
voulez va s'investir il faudrait
malheureusement qui met le nez dans la
stratégie de la boîte et c'est là où
naziha packham qu'elle a un point sur
lequel l'état peut s'impliquer
moi je vous dis ça je connais tu connais
rien a mis ce qu'on entend depuis ce
matin c'est qu'il faudrait instituer des
normes qui protège que actuellement en
tout cas les normes ne s'impliquaient
homologue ne s'impose coupe ne qui sont
sortis d'usiné et là dans ce match là
effectivement comme le disait vincent
très mal et tout à l'heure les pneus
chinois sont gagnants parce que ils sont
20% moins cher ou fabriqués dans
d'autres zones en europe parce qu'il ya
une concurrence intra européens aussi il
ya une concurrence intra-européenne dont
je vous prends l'exemple de l'accord des
plats chinois est ce qu'on entendait
également ce matin c'est que beaucoup de
constructeurs notamment michelin demande
que ces normes s'impose également sur
des pneus qui ont été déjà utilisée
qu'on puisse les normes d'homologation
puisse apposer sur les plans qui sont
déjà utilisés et dans ce cas là les
pneus qui sont fabriqués de la
concurrence qui sont fabriqués en chine
ne tiendrait pas si je puis dire la
route par rapport aux pneus bridgestone
ou pneus michelin est ce que l'état
français m'avaient pas des normes de
protection quand même qu'ils pourraient
cesser au fait ça va dans ce sens la
serre que si on veut maintenir des
industries de ce genre en france il faut
changer des règles du jeu parce que si
si les règles
elle s'impose évidemment les ouvriers
français seront perdants à la fin donc
il faut vraiment un état qui soit
stratège dans la définition de ce qu'est
la qualité environnementale sociale et
aussi quelque part quand il accorde des
aides dans la manière dont elles sont
utilisées parce que là effectivement il
ya beaucoup d'entreprises qui chasse les
prix mais c'est ce que reproche xavier
bertrand à bridgestone quand il dit que
c'est un assassinat prémédité c'est à
dire que finalement les grands groupes
font survivre la boîte l'unité de
production aussi longtemps que c'est
possible avec des des aides publiques
mais ne font pas les efforts nécessaires
pour lui assurer une viabilité à long
terme et ce sont ces de l'investissement
c'est de la recherche ces voiles à
cesser d'essayer de de maintenir une
production de qualité et on a vu ce
scénario se reproduire alors dans le
pneu ça a été une série donc c'est aussi
pour ça que la le la colère le
ressentiment est aussi visible c'est que
mais il ya eu les conti les goodyear et
maintenant les bridgestone et on a
l'impression que rien ne change mais
alors là justement c'est ce que disait
vincent tout ça est ce que c'est pas
aussi pardonnez-moi mais le sens de
l'histoire dans la mesure où sans doute
on va on s'achemine vers un recul de
l'utilisation de la voiture en tous les
cas aujourd'hui rien n'est pour le
moment les relations se sont effondrés
oui en france je mets femmes et mais
pour le moment je crois qu'elle est
celle du marché mondial face est pas
enfin c'est pas encore décisif alors je
suis pas du tout spécialiste de la chose
automobile mais mais j'ai un peut
interroger des gens je crois que c'est
pas décisif pour revenir à ce que disait
sylvain courage
si l'état doit changer de mentalité en
fait il y a aussi le problème de
l'opinion publique c'est à dire que et
c'est là c'est un problème qu'on rejoint
d'ailleurs sur le co vide et qui est un
problème à mon avis très compliqué
aujourd'hui dans le rapport des français
à la politique c'est que on demande à
l'état un certain nombre de choses peut
être légitimement mais on exige aussi
les tailles du marché un certain nombre
de choses et pour être très concret si
on disait on va garder cette usine mais
vous paierez vos pneus 10% plus cher ou
20% plus cher
je ne sais pas si l'indignation de la
population serait la même oreille à un
moment il n'est pas possible
d'acheter fine on a des choses faites
dans des conditions sociales déplorables
et conscience environnementale
scandaleuse mais qui fait que le t-shirt
est à 3 euros et ensuite de demander
qu'ils soient fabriqués chez des années
de façon socialement acceptable et envie
écologiquement correct ça n'est pas
possible
donc là on se retrouve devant une
contradiction ou au fait
l'individu et la dea droit illimité
qu'ils reportent sur l'état qui à mon
avis a pour première faute de lui faire
croire qu'il pourrait défendre tous ses
droits
or il ne le peut pas la phrase de jospin
on peut pas me taxer de nouveau spin
mais la phrase de jose passer un accès
de vérité et de franchise qui est très
rare en politique et qui est plus franc
que les indignations que l'on entend
depuis ce matin l'état alors il ya
quelque chose que je vous entends là où
sur un point sur lequel je vous entends
pas et je sais les internautes notamment
les internautes du figaro killing de
nous rejoindre
on est désolé d'ailleurs on a eu un
petit bug et donc voilà maintenant on
est sur la home du figaro on est content
de vous retrouver vous nous expliquez
vous exprimer vous nous donnez vos
points de vue je salue ceux qui sont
exprimés également sur youtube et sur
facebook notamment dan qui dit ce qui
est sympa dans les lacs du figaro c'est
que vous prenez en compte les
commentaires alors on y va
martha snowdy l'état n'a pas son mot à
dire car il doit se plier aux règles
imposées par l'union européenne ya pas
ce problème également sous jacent
peut-être pas dans cette affaire mais
dans souvent dans certaines ben oui
puisque
disons que la souveraineté nationale sur
les règles et sur les règles économiques
bas et les voilà elle est limitée
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que l'essentiel
des des normes sont édictées par
l'europe les grands accords commerciaux
aussi
donc effectivement on est dans un
échelon supranationale et on a du mal à
organiser la riposte à l'échelle
européenne
d'abord parce qu'il ya des intérêts
divergents
il ya certains si nous on ferme des
usines de pneus il ya encore des pays
qui on ouvre dans certains cas dans
l'europe de l'est là donc on comprend
bien que c'est difficile du coup de
faire des règles pour vol en roumanie en
bulgarie
voilà exactement et et du coup ça c'est
un énorme problème parce
qu'effectivement il faudrait organiser
cette défense économique à l'échelle
européenne et là encore je pense que
tous les politiciens français
signeraient de de rassemblement national
jusqu'à à jean luc mélenchon ils sont
d'accord là dessus
alors il ya un élément quand même
nouveau parce que sylvain courage je
parlais tout à l'heure des comptes idée
goodyear et c'est en disant c'est une
espèce de litanies infini ce qu'elle
changera rien mais le jeu vers le
défenseur de l'état alors que du côté
libéral de la force mais le le
confinement et la crise sur les dix
terre que l'on a vécu et la crise
économique qui l'a accompagné à montrer
et a donné à l'état un rôle qu'il
n'avait plus et notamment avec le
président de la start up nation qui
s'est retrouvé comme le président le
plus étatiste peut-être des 30 dernières
années et qui fait qu'il doit y avoir
chez les responsables publics
peut-être une détermination plus forte
vis-à-vis des entreprises parce qu'ils
les ont quand même porter pour le coup à
bout de bras et abou d'euros donc c'est
en ça que peut-être cette histoire n'est
pas la énième histoire d'un processus
qui de toute façon dont on connaît la
fin peut-être que justement il participe
de la réflexion que tous les pays
occidentaux mènent sur la nécessité
d'avoir un état parce que là on l'a vu
on l'a vérifié tous les jours depuis le
depuis mois de mars et la question vous
est posée en ce moment sur le site du
figaro le gouvernement a t-il raison
d'intervenir dans le dossier bridgestone
et bien les vopos continuent à voter
ceux qui ont déjà voté
c'est une question à ce pas un sondage
mais ont déjà répondu oui sur le site du
figaro donc à 58% plus vincent je
reviens sur ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure sur effectivement est-ce qu'il
serait socialement acceptable de payer
plus cher
quelque chose qui est produit localement
par rapport à quelque chose qui est
produit à l'extérieur mais ça fait un
pas sur sur un point et c'est dan qui
soulève cette histoire à 7,7 cette
objection lorsqu'on libéraliser son
économie sans protectionnisme ça peut
pas bien se passer
s'il n'y a pas des taxes sur des
produits qui sont produit justement dans
des conditions comme le disent
socialement inacceptable et
écologiquement condamnable mais le
libéralisme peut se développer sans
protectionnisme avec une réciprocité
on peut quand même demandé aux chinois
et aux américains une réciprocité nous
on applique leurs règles ils
n'appliquent pas les nôtres donc c'est
comme extraordinaire c'est à dire que
nous si on veut exporter en chine aux
états unis on habille et des normes
qu'on doit suivre et l'europe l'europe
parle par exemple est la raison d'une
barrière carbone qui devrait faire payer
un impôt sur le coût écologique d'un
certain nombre de productions qui
viendraient fait nous mais à ma
connaissance pour le moment ça reste à
l'état de projet et ça n'est pas une
réalisation concrète et parce que
l'europe jusqu'à peut maintenant elle a
compris a vécu dans le rêve de
l'abolition absolu de toute règle
économique de toute frontière de tout de
toute protection hors non mais c'est pas
ça veut pas dire dressé non plus et
c'est une réciprocité c'est la phrase
très célèbre d'hubert védrine on se
comporte en biseau s'avère qu'on est
dans jurassic park ben on va quand on
est ado jura c'est pas qu'on essaye au
moins de demander aux d'avoir les mêmes
règles que ceux qui nous attaquent
je vous donne la parole encore cher
interne florent il faudrait boycotter
les produits de cette usine c'est ce
qu'on nous dit sur facebook
fouad quand on voit les bénéfices de
cette entreprise cela me met dans une
colère énorme bénigne ou une
multinationale à une stratégie à très
long terme le processus de fermeture a
certainement commencé il ya pas mal
d'années c'est en tout cas ce que pense
xavier bertrand quoi que dise l'état
estime yves et vous joël ces grandes
entreprises sont au final ce qu'elles
veulent la faire bridgestone démontre
juste la faiblesse de l'état le
gouvernement a t-il raison d'intervenir
dans le dossier bridge chose c'est la
question qu'on vous pose sur le site du
figaro nous pourrons continuer à voter
de jusqu'à demain à la mi journée où
vous aurez les résultats définitifs un
dernier mot sur sur cette affaire comme
la suite de la suite de la suite des
opérations justement puisqu'il ya une
indignation quand même qui est massive
qu'effectivement le contexte a changé
après la crise sanitaire est l'aveu que
l'état est fondée à agir
il va falloir maintenant trouver un mode
d'action parce que sinon ça ça risque
quand même à nouveau de de creuser le
fossé entre
les citoyens et l'état et puis aussi
retarder la prise de conscience
nécessaire de en europe donc c'est un
dossier qu'il faut suivre je veux dire
c'est la vie politique joue gros parce
qu'ils vont tous défilé ou
symboliquement ou physiquement tous deux
de l'extrême droite à l'extrême gauche
du gouvernement et xavier bertrand et
donc si à l'arrivée c'est simplement
pour déplorer
ce serait quand même une expression
nouvelle de l'impossibilité du politique
qui équivalent le la grande crise
politique dans laquelle on essaie
l'impossibilité de l'exécution en fait
on dit qu'on fait des choses en fait on
ne peut pas les faire donc là c'est
c'est un fou cette affaire c'est un cas
concret à 4 est très concret il ya un
autre cas concrets que je voudrais vous
soumettre ce soir c'est le deuxième
thème de ce débat ce soir c'est la
première plainte contre jean castex
alors qu'heuliez vive on doit prendre la
parole sur la gestion de la crise du
chauve et il parle actuellement on peut
y suivre en direct d'ailleurs sur le
site du figaro mais avant vous êtes avec
nous ce que ça va durer donc jean castex
et visez donc par une première plainte
pour la gestion de la crise du coc vide
alors le motif invoqué par l'avocat des
plaignants c'est un collectif de 200
plaignants qui s'appelle le collectif
victime coronavirus france et l'avocat
c'est le désormais célèbre fabrice di
vizio vrsac été avocat de la ligue
droits de l'homme et qui a été en pointe
dans les plaintes contre le gouvernement
depuis la crise sanitaire liée au carnet
virus
il déclare le premier ministre tient un
discours alarmiste mais prend des
mesures minimales mais minimaliste ou
alors stupide est il un vote
il invoque l'article 223 7 du code pénal
qui met en cause je cite l'abstention
volontaire de prendre ou de provoquer
des mesures permettant de combattre un
sinistre de nature à créer un danger
pour la sécurité des personnes
sylvain courage est-ce que non ça va pas
un peu trop loin circulez
c'est à cette association et cet avocat
poursuit sa logique comme ils ont déjà
introduit des plaintes contre le
gouvernement précédent ils veulent pas
que ça s'arrête là responsabilité
s'arrête au changement de gouvernement
en juillet en plus jean castex a été
monsieur déconfinement donc ils veulent
mais ils veulent le mettre en cause pour
que l' enquête soit complète
ça c'est un peu la logique que sa
logique parce que c'est justifié
bah moi j'ai quand même un problème avec
cette idée de mettre en cause
systématiquement la responsabilité
juridique des gouvernants parce que la
politique c'est d'abord une
responsabilité politique qui sont
responsables devant les électeurs ils
peuvent commettre des fautes mais là on
a l'impression que dans tout dans tous
leurs actes finalement on pourrait les
accusés de négligence et donc cette
judiciarisation du rapport entre les
citoyens et l'état
quand même une nouveauté un peu
effrayante parce qu'on voit pas très
bien comment on peut aller au bout de ce
de cette logique là et comment comment
quelqu'un osera à l'avenir se présenter
devant le suffrage des citoyens pour
dire moi je vais assumer la
responsabilité et vous avez le droit si
quelque chose ne vous revient pas de me
traîner devant les tribunaux aux fins et
c'est un peu un dévoiement de la
démocratie je trouve alors il faut
qu'ils aient des évidemment des
garde-fous mais je pense que c'est quand
même asymétrique alors là non point de
vue se rejoignent absolument parce que
moi il me semble même qui est qu'on
devrait durcir les décisions contre les
plaintes abusives pour justement
décourager un certain nombre de
plaignants qui dans toute circonstance
soit pour se faire de la publicité
médiatique soit pour essayer d'obtenir
quelque chose s'en prennent à l'état moi
je ne suis pas d'accord quand on dit que
les politiques doit être jugé que
politiquement il son port du droit
commun donc il est beau c'est sûr mais
d'ailleurs il ya dans l'article qui dit
il est possible mais là l'article
invoquée par m division c'est ce serait
l'équivalent dans les listes dépêchés
dans la région catholique du péché par
omission en gros ils ont prise
il aurait pu faire quelque chose qu'ils
n'ont pas fait donc mon mais ça on peut
le dire à chaque fois que l'on peut le
dire encore plus dans une là il faut
quand même reconnaître au gouvernement
français à tous les gouvernements du
monde le fait qu'ils avancent dans un
brouillard d'une opacité inouïe personne
ne sait quand cette chose-là va se
terminer personne ne sait l'ampleur de
la deuxième vague si elle va avoir lieu
ou pas et c'est pour ça qu'ils avancent
à tâtons et c'est pour ça que castex
fait une déclaration qui fut non
déclaration parce que ils sont devant
leur lors que leurs colonnes de chiffres
les coups de fil des ars ils se disent
on peut peut-être traverser la rue sans
s'enfermer
mais en même temps il faut pas bon on
peut faire des critiques politiques par
exemple on peut dire que sur les masques
il ya eu un mensonge d'état
ça c'est vrai on peut peut-être
s'étonner du fait qu' il ya des gens
commencent là que pour des tests à 4
heures du matin et qu'ils auront les
résultats de leurs tests
quand de toute façon peut-être ne vaudra
plus rien parce qu'il aura huit jours ça
oui mais de là à ça on peut le faire de
façon comme on fait là dans des tribunes
ou de façon politique mais de là à aller
jusqu'au juge
ça me paraît parfaitement excessif et ça
rejoint ce que je disais tout à l'heure
cette idée que maintenant l'état doit
tout empêcher tout protégé chez
l'individu et sané ça n'est pas possible
c'est quand même l'état français
aujourd'hui est faible on a beaucoup
entendu au moment d'une confinement et
après la passion administratives comme
s'il y avait une espèce de volonté d'un
état tyrannique de profiter du moment
moi je crois pas du tout moi je pense
que l'état est très faible et qui suis
mis à table il n'y a pas une espèce
d'obésité administratif qui n'ont il
peut y avoir une réponse de l'état comme
s'appellent de l'empiré salon normative
de génie français de dire que dans telle
rue on peut passer à telle heure avec un
mass en masse comme du début bon mais
mais c'est le premier levier dans cette
histoire c'est l'opinion publique c'est
de l'opinion publique qui a peur de
cette épidémie de façon légitime et qui
demande à l'état de la protéger c'est
pas l'état qui se fait le protecteur au
niveau mini potent parce qu'il a le
désir d'étendre son pouvoir sur les
individus là je pense qu'il ya vraiment
dans cette critique que l'on a pu
entendre une critique excessive après
l'état s'est montré parfois arbitraire
parfois absurde mais parce que c'est de
la machine administrative qui souvent
doit s'ajuster et bon bah on l'a vu sur
les masques au début on comprenait rien
et maintenant on arrivé un truc qui est
à peu près qu'ils acceptaient je crois
par 90% de la population donc c'est
quand même pour quelque chose qui est
assez pénible pas rien traîner la
politique de traîner les politiques de
l'injustice des dix jura entraîne une
peur de la condamnation ce qui risque de
leur faire prendre deux mots de
mauvaises décisions
christian mahmoudi pour moi c'est
injuste jean castex fait son mieux
fabrice di vizio était invité dans une
émission de zemmour et naulleau pendant
le confinement et eric delvaux on a pris
à partie en lit en lui disant finalement
dans ce que dans ce que vous faites vous
en paix
vous tétanisé les politiques et du coup
ne peuvent plus ils peuvent
c'est vrai que ça crée une pression et
je crois que même d'or philippe tout
edouard philippe qu'il était c'est à
dire quelqu'un de plutôt calme et qui
philosophe il il l'a très mal pris c'est
cesser ses attaques judiciaires mais
c'est vrai que ça peut paralyser l'état
dans la fameuse dialectique du masque
c'est clair que les français on se sont
tournés vers latins en disant protéger
les nums et l'état aujourd'hui l'ordi
protégez-vous en mettant le masque en
avant mais enfin on voit bien que
il n'y a pas grand-chose qui progresse
dans un échange là chacun se renvoie la
responsabilité
il est évident que la vérité quelque
part au milieu c'est à dire qu'il faut
un état éclairé qui s'appuie sur la
science mais qu'ils fassent confiance
aussi aux citoyens puisque les français
se plaignent aussi d'être infantilisés
tout en réclamant une protection
permanente donc on est quand même dans
des injonctions contradictoires qui font
qu est très difficile d'y voir clair moi
pour ce qui est de la responsabilité des
politiques je pense qu'il ya une
instance qui est très juste et très
utile c'est la commission d' enquête
parlementaire qui peut déboucher ensuite
sur des mises en cause judiciaires mais
c'est l'asse la bonne manière de traiter
c'est le bon niveau pour traiter cela
avec une représentation nationale
du pluralisme dans l'instruction et on
voit ce que ça donne et on a un résultat
et les politiques sont quand même
surveiller il ya un contrôle qualité qui
est effectué oui mais le danger quand
même et on l'a vu peut-être pendant la
première période de la crise c'est que
les décisions ne se font plus à l'aune
du bien commun en disant qu est ce que
je dois faire de bien pour ma ville ou
pour mon département mais du risque
pénal que j'encours et ça c'est quand
même un vice poison dans les mers sont
prisonniers
c'est vraiment un poison parce qu'il ya
des décisions qui nous apparaissent
comme un sens c est quand on sent
n'ouvre à ceux qui les prennent ou est
ce qu'ils les relais ils disent bah oui
mais vous êtes gentil mais vous risquez
pas parce que c'est vrai qu'il doit
flipper philosophe mais il connaît aussi
son histoire politique et le sang
contaminé ses dix ans de d'affaires
judiciaires pour laurent fabius et une
carrière politique bon kick quand même
allés assez haut mais qui a été empêchée
non mais c'est quand même dix ans d'une
existence est donc enfin vivre avec ce
ce comment dire cette cette angoisse là
n'est pas tenable et je trouve moi
quelque chose de courageux chez castex
et macron dans la décision qu'ils ont
pris vendredi dernier c'est que la
facilité c'était de tout fermé parce que
de toute façon la liste avait pas deux
équipes comme il ya la nécessité
économique et social parce que je pense
que la dimension sociale a été intégrée
par l'exécutif en disant ne peut pas
dire aux gens de leur vie va être
simplement la vie physiologique
ils ont tenu mais ils ont été très
critiqués là le fait de ne pas prendre
de décisions sévères leur a valu un
certain nombre de critiques alors j'ai
une autre question quand même quand on
voit que edouard philippe qui est
poursuivi et qui a été donc à mal pris
ces plaintes restent populaires qui
incarne pour 4 pour 58% des français
la figure de l'autorité est ce que
finalement ces mêmes ces plaintes ça
peut ça peut nuire à castex je pense pas
que ça puisse lui nuire gagné 1 28% dans
le bar est de oui mais dans le cas
d'edouard philippe il ya eu une phase où
c'est vrai que peut-être le gouvernement
était pris de court on en a évoqué tout
à l'heure parce que tous manqué les
masques l'était c'est que ça et au bout
d'un moment il a il a résolu de dire la
vérité c'est à dire écoutez voilà moi je
suis en responsabilité je vous dis ce
que je fais voilà pourquoi je fais les
choses il a expliqué finalement il s'est
appuyé sur la sur la partie la plus la
plus responsable à plus adulte des
citoyens français et c'est ça que
qui lui vaut cette popularité clairement
donc finalement il a il a retrouvé un
fonctionnement politique ce contrat de
confiance entre les lecteurs et l'élu
entre le mandaté et ses mandants et on
partage d'informations et on essaie de
faire au mieux et sans confiance
en vérité il peut pas y avoir de société
il peut pas y avoir de politique donc
les gens ont fini par faire confiance à
philippe c'est ça son tour de force à
l'avant sans simplement
ouais ce qui est très intéressant dans
cette notion qui est invoquée la mention
à celle autorités c'est à dire que
edouard philippe à imposer son autorité
sans aucun effet de manche pendant qu
emmanuel macron disait c'est la guerre
devant une tente militaire et sans
aucune promesses mirobolantes ou coup de
mantoue il a il a simplement été à la
bonne mesure et à la bonne distance que
lui imposer sa charge et c'est très rare
et je pense c'est vraiment ça qui l'a
réussi et même son éloquence était sobre
lors des conférences de presse qui
faisait et à la fin on se disait cette
personne est habité par l'idée de faire
le mieux possible dans cette crise et et
je pense c'est une perspective politique
aujourd'hui qui a de l'avenir parce qu
on est très tenté enfin par les
personnalités extravagantes et je pense
que les moulinet ça marche plus
d'ailleurs dans ce sondage dans votre
manuel valls est à 28 % et manuel valls
étaient une des personnalités qui a le
plus porté l'autorité dans son
expression extérieur langage théâtral et
je pense que ça fonctionne plus mais
casting de ce jour là n'en fait mais
d'un autre côté nicolas sarkozy qui a
été quand même quelqu'un qui a mis en
scène entre les câbles l'autorité de
l'état arrive juste derrière
oui mais parce que sarkozy a peut
invoquer un bilan
qui est discutable on pourra dire cela
mais il a quand même été au fait de son
passage à beauvau à 2012 une espèce de
ministres intérieur pendant dix ans qui
fait qu'il appréhende t cette notion là
mais il est quand même pas le premier
non plus d'ailleurs c'est alors
qu'edouard philippe sur le régalien ne
s'est jamais tellement exprimé dans bon
disciple de l'âge de pc pas le coeur de
ses préoccupations
donc c'est quand même intéressant qu'il
acquit qui il arrive à faire ce score
les plans d'une corrida n'a d'ailleurs
samedi les plans du gouvernement sont
floues et c'est le coeur du problème
forcément ils sont floues parce qu'on
essaie de trouver un compromis entre bon
les nécessités sanitaires et puis les
impératifs économiques et sociaux on
sait ce que coûte le confinement même
partiel ces ralentissements de
l'activité c'est des emplois qui
disparaissent c'est des gens qui qui qui
décrochent socialement donc il faut
trouver un chemin de crête entre ses
contraintes ses contradictions
donc c'est pas très claires et en plus
la situation non plus n'est pas si clair
parce qu'au début de l'épidémie c'est
vrai qu'on suivait la couronne la courbe
de la mortalité les lits de réanimation
est ce qu'on allait tenir extérieur
aujourd'hui est à la fois un nombre de
cas en augmentation mais du point de vue
d'être dangerosité on observe plutôt mon
c'est plutôt maîtrisé en tout cas les
les cas les cas graves ne se multiplient
pas donc c'est pour ça aussi que on est
un peu dans du comment dire d'embrayage
quoi il faut manier l'accélérateur et
l'embrayage pour pour faire avancer à la
bonne vitesse et essai et c'est flou
quand même dans ce flou c'est que macron
a maintenant décidé il ya deux lignes
qui sont affrontés y en a une c'est à
dire a indiqué l'épidémie complètement
et puis l'autre c'est la gestion du
risque et macron a décidé la gestion du
risque c'est à dire ce qu'il appelle on
est passé de c'est la guerre vivre avec
le virus et vivre avec le virus
ça veut dire on va accepter qu'il y ait
quelques billets y ait quelques malades
qu'il y ait malheureusement quelques
morts parce qu'on ne peut pas arrêter
intégralement le la société pour ça et
donc ce qu'ils vont essayer de jouer
d'après ce qu'on comprend c'est
justement que simplement les hôpitaux
puissent de façon réguler traiter les
malades n'est pas ce qu'on a pu croire
un moment au mois de juillet on
comprenait plus grand chose si on
voulait arriver à zéro contaminé quoi
s'il fallait qui est plus du tout de
porter du coc vide en france apparemment
ils ont changé de stratégie
va-t-on va-t-on de 10 fracas va-t-on
ressembler aux états unis où l'on ait
fait des procès pour tout et n'importe
quoi
dan estime en revanche que le procès
d'un moindre des choses vu des mensonges
proférés par l'état ces derniers mois et
estime également que l'état le procès
permettrait d'analyser objectivement les
erreurs à ne pas refaire et vous ce que
vous disiez cinéma et c'est que ça c'est
plutôt le travail de la commission
parlementaire les commissions pas oui
enfin parce que parce que c'est un
règlement politique mais qui peut
déboucher si les fautes
réel au regard du code pénal sont sont
observés traduite ensuite en poursuite
je pense que c'est une meilleure prise
en charge collective de la
responsabilité des politiques
maintenant il ya une école américaine
c'est vrai qu'ils se développent avec
des avocats d'ailleurs qui procède
exactement de la même manière que les
avocats américains sauf qu'on n'a pas
vraiment de classe a ction enfin on n'a
pas exactement l'équivalent de ce qui
existe aux états-unis sauf que il
regroupe des des plaignants une
association et ensuite ils font une
percée médiatique en attaquant on sait
pas trop ce que vont devenir ces
plaintes est ce qu elles vont toutes
être mais de toute façon déjà une partie
voilà et absurdités que la salle il ya
une nouvelle erreur donc le parquet a
fait son travail devant la cour de
justice de la république je sais pas
trop comment ça va se passer mais moi je
suis très attentif à la commission d
enquête parlementaire je pense que c'est
moi je pense que bien malin est celui
qui peut juger
qui peut savoir comment mâcon sera jugée
à la sortie de cette histoire parce que
là si dan ou un autre de nos auditeurs
ou de téléspectateurs et n'est pas
satisfait il peut porter plainte il peut
aussi ne pas voter pour magron la
prochaine élection ça sert à ça mais
moi je pense que quand on sera sorti
tout ça les gens vont se dire est ce que
les choses ont été faites à peu près
bien et est ce que j'ai gardé mon boulot
est ce que l'état ici et ça se jouera là
tu es là c'est impossible de savoir
aujourd'hui de quel côté la pièce va
tomber parce que on n'a pas d'équivalent
politique on a passé six fois qu'on voit
là on a pas de situation politique on
peut dire untel aurait fait mieux ou at
elle n'aurait pas fait mais merci pour
vos explications claires et précises
ça c'est moi qui me lit mais c'est
surtout christian qui nous lisent sur le
site du figaro merci crédit en tous les
cas nous avoir suivis la plainte contre
jean castex pour cette gestion de la
crise du colis dix neuf est elle
justifiée et elle mérite et c'est la
question qu'on me pose est sur twitter
et vous êtes une majorité à répondre non
à 58 % avaient un merci d'avoir été là
merci d'avoir participé pardon pour les
bugs de début d'émission et on se
retrouve demain même heure même endroit
avec carl meeus ferghana ziyaye de
l'iref
le cimt aux antilles le think tank
libéral anti impôts et le politologue et
guillaume bernard merci alemanno lisa
qui me le dire dans l'oreillette
merci beaucoup à tradition figurent die
[Musique]